I think O'Dell is probably the scariest
been saying this for years none of us
like to see champ walk in the room when
we playing poker chance pockets were
deeper than the rest of us Sims enough
go what is up what is good yo what up
with you back here I feel good champ
Bailey's coming up soon but he scared
you in practice yes he'd scare you too
if you could throw I'll tell you the
best throw it was more of a run after a
throw right kenyon jury what the Miami
miracle yeah I was watching here in the
office Omar house a highlights guy lost
his mind where were you when it happened
I was at NBC was nuts going nuts yelling
because he kept going Tony Dungy was
like oh wow wow but we talked I looked
in the camera last week and said you're
crazy if you don't think the playoffs
are going through New England right then
that happened yeah and now you're crazy
if the playoffs aren't going through
Kansas City right right they have that
two-game lead yeah that felt like a huge
shift in power is that going to change
the entire playoffs I think it
definitely increases the chance of the
Chiefs getting to the Super Bowl in the
AFC I think that's what it does more
than anything I mean one thing we've
seen with New England if there's a flaw
and there's not many flaws with New
England they haven't won a road playoff
game since 2006 now granted they played
some good teams on the road whether that
was Peyton Manning's Colts or
those Denver Bronco defenses yeah and
dealing with that in the Mile House
State Mile High Stadium but the big
thing is you get New England out of New
England New England's like the old
Yankee Stadium when you walk in there
you're like the ghost of Belichick and
Brady are haunting me and can we
overcome this crowd and because they
understand how good their team is the
crowd stays quiet and Brady can make 9
million checks in the line of scrimmage
and they look like audio recording stuff
in your locker room know that you're
saying they cut off your communication I
love that Belichick and Brady have dos
and they're still alive that's all good
that's how good they are
what's up at the Baker Mayfield you're
watching Sims and
Bleacher Report so we want to put our
guests to work Champ Bailey top three
top five corner all-time and I think
he's in the top five discussion I mean
I'm not just gonna go out crazy Hall of
Fame three Hollis hall of famer get a
minivan come on guys you can exaggerate
no practice against that actually scared
me in practice there's a lot of good
wide receivers in the league right now I
want to know how you'd cover them first
one Tyree kill so your Tyree kill step
to the line you know me I'm Tyree killer
all right you're Tyree kill okay really
absolutely both fast remember both fast
I won't do this every play but I gotta
get in your face I gotta let you know
I'm here right I mean that's my bread
and butter
yup and right now I'm not stupid right
it's boy wearing the 42 maybe a 4-1 so
I'm aware of that before I play it so my
idea of playing him from the line of
scrimmage is I got to stay in front of
it right you hear this old cliche get
your hands on them and forget that it's
not about getting your hands on them
it's about staying in front of him right
okay making it hard for him to get there
right that's the easy one that's the one
they want and you're not gonna try to
jam them of course you weren't sure I
think the hands a secondary right so I
got to stay on top of it he wants to run
a 15-yard comeback curl you can have
that yeah I'm gonna come down I'm a
pound you all day
all right I'm going timeout right
because I believe you see the film yeah
I think a lot of coroner's have thought
that what Tyree kill this year yeah and
then we're talking about me though I
know I'm talking about you I know this
one made clear but if he did open up on
you and it looked even faster than it
was on film are you are you coming out
earlier I'm just saying like I haven't
seen anyone that's are you saying it
that if if my film study didn't show the
real speed oh I didn't ya feel it and
now I'm and you got out there and he was
even faster than you thought he was
getting and that happened before DeSean
Jackson fast one of the fastest guys
I've seen right probably fast as I've
ever covered right he he blew past me on
the first play and I'm chasing I'm like
oh my god it's got something I thought I
played off him a little more than I
wanted to but at the same time I still
got up in his face when I had the chance
you know it's just being aware
of what the situations are there's a lot
of layers to it yeah I could go on and
on about let's do another one
Antonio Brown right there's part of me
that believes that if you saw Antonio
Brown its lockup status its I got to get
my hands on a [ __ ] I'm super physical
am i right you're right
I'm gonna tell you why you're right
because film study tells me this is what
I know because I've played against them
I've seen him throughout the years he
has a hard time with big long corners
right Richard Sherman gives them hell
hell hell so so I'm aware of that and no
one factors this in requires you give
them hell right you know it's hard for
him right and why is it hard for him
because they stay in front of him they
make it heart he can't run around him
right just wiggle and just go the tape
will tell you everything tape doesn't
lie
I agree what about going toe-to-toe with
a Julio for that long like is that
physically demanding like are you
exhausted more after that game than
after a game against Antonio Brown you
know a guy like that he's bigger so he's
not gonna have the same release but he's
stronger
so which your feet really play a role
there because if you're just standing
there with your arms out like this you
know I love Brandon you know I mean yeah
these guys yeah grab you they want you
to grab them but I'll try to get my
hands on them but it's really more about
my positioning you know I just want to
make sure that I have a strong
foundation because they'll throw you by
they'll grab your helmet I mean it
doesn't matter fish sterling I mean he
said the king of that grab you pull you
right and another thing you have to
worry about is blocking you do block
there of all the guys right now whether
it's Odell Julio Keenan Allen Antonio
Brown DeAndre Hopkins Tyree kill which
one of you go in 60 minutes I could get
anything I could get everything it's
gonna cause me to earn my paycheck the
most well I think Odell is probably the
scariest because his run out to the
catch is superb I mean his first step is
superb yes there's really not a lot of
weaknesses in his game yeah he could
catch everything right you know what's
route running is excellent right you
know so you've been saying this for
years
oh yeah yeah well people want to hate on
Odell I get it I mean he's a little
flamboyant like some limelight like the
dance yeah so what but what does he do
between the line
that's all that matters right so you
know that's why people love to hate on
tio but tio was one of the best ever
right and you know just you know just
watching his game there's really not a
lot of weaknesses yeah playing a simple
yeah I love the fact that we got to see
how you'd play the guys the other aspect
of defending a wide receiver the
quarterback eyes we've had a few
secondary guys here Landon Collins Jamal
Adams they kind of shared that staring
contest with the quarterback and you're
trying to figure it out is there one
that pops to your head right away of
whether it's a Peyton or a Brady or
somebody that game where they either got
you or you got them really good you know
Phillip Rivers probably those guys you
always let you know when he got you you
know I hated him for about two years
great guy love him to death right but he
was just hard to deal with you know
because he would you could tell he
studied your weaknesses because you know
he would find those moments when you
just weren't paying attention
and he knew he couldn't attack me the
whole game but he had his moments when
he would just throw it in there squeeze
it in there and God was accurate ball
looks like it's floating but it's not I
feel like he would say something to hey
would ya yeah I got you right there or
he you know you come back and you jumped
that one I'll do that again or something
a crazy like that it's like half the
time I don't know what he's saying yeah
but I know he's just talking trash and
just you know he's the competitive dude
yeah and I appreciate it more now than I
did then you played with Deion Sanders
in DC what was that year like with him
like what'd you learn from him just
being around him you know it's not just
him it's Darryl Greene Johnson
so I had diagram a rookie yeah yeah and
then Deon comes in I got okay to Hall of
Famers they're already Hall of Famers at
that point right yes right so I'm
thinking okay you know I got two guys I
could learn from first of all before he
even got there I'm worried if I'm gonna
start but everybody made it clear yeah
you're gonna start of course you're
gonna start you know we're gonna start
but I'm thinking like that these are two
dudes I look up to like how do I start
over them both of them Wow and they're
prime I don't love to see them race all
through you really that a bit of Ty
oh I don't know yeah Darryl was a track
guy yeah I was a track Darryl when I was
a jumper and Dionne was a sprinter as
well so that's hard I gotta say I gotta
say Darryl because he at least one to
you know fastest man he once is a
fastest man a few times I give him there
okay so then what about you Andy hey you
know maybe we're neck-and-neck you know
I can't give him anything Hall of Fame
were these stories Simms has shared a
lot from his career beautiful seven
eight years of NFL glory the poker games
in Denver we had fun
first of all but none of us like to see
champ walk in the room when we playing
poker like we all know yeah yeah but
champs pockets were deeper than the rest
of us so you know that was the cheapest
guy well he might have been the cheapest
he wasn't afraid to throw a little money
around every now and then too every now
yeah and I want to buy him out of this
pot I know he doesn't have a grams a
good buddy yet he had he had big big
stacks of cash that team with Denver so
who would be in these poker rooms oh man
ham Brandon Marshall Lamont Jordan $800
in left town last time we played really
you're that I'm bringing that up Tony
should we go finally I want $100 one
night he I don't have the money on me
right now
I'll bring by the check in the next day
or two lives like three days later I
never saw it yeah what do you got going
on right now oh well you know I'm I
invested in this company okay W Hills
and basically they make these sucks
laso sucks and what they do they mimic
ankle taping and one thing every athlete
hates is taping their ankles yes you
know so worse this isn't worse these
things feel so good I wear them every
day got them on now I mean and for old
guy that doesn't run around anymore I
can only imagine if I was young and
playing what these would do for me you
want to know more about it lasso gear
calm tell you everything about the Sun
backed by technology great socks it
what's up this is your boy Nate Burleson
yeah the guy with the best flow out here
in New York all the way from the west
coast I came to talk that talk and I
same with my chest Oh keep it lock right
here uh-huh
Samson left Co Nate Burleson that's flow
a tree he's got a seal I like that you
got a skill too very well I'm gonna
challenge date one day I'm gonna go down
a good morning football rap battle I'm
feel pretty confident I like it it'd be
good he's done a lot for your life
I mean tell you how to do some handshake
he has really did Thank You days up your
game Chargers Chiefs fantastic Thursday
Night Football game 11 into 10 and 3 are
you expecting a shootout will live up to
the billing
I think so because every Chiefs game has
lived up to the billing
it's unbelievable the way they play in
general Thursday night I always favor
the home team but yes the shootout I do
think is just it's gonna happen in this
game I don't see how the Kansas City
Chiefs can match up with all the
receivers on the Los Angeles chargers
down the board at some point there's
gonna be a mismatch issue I do think it
stinks that they don't have a Melvin
Gordon or maybe they're not gonna have
an echoer we're really not sure at this
point I know so that's going to hurt
them a little bit because they do like
to run the ball play action but I still
think this is a high-scoring affair and
I expect the Chiefs to come out on top
all right well hold on we have to toss
to somebody and left okay fine let's
toss this because you know who's a
better picture than you nobody no say
his name his name
Ali Ali Ali let's go see what Ali the
Oracle has to say you signed it i
autographed it thank you
how you doing on this because there's
three seats here - yeah
man so you're a little surprised I am
I'm glad you came to see me cuz I don't
know why now you said you were coming to
see me so I figure that comes to you I
will eventually I need to pay this man
as money okay give me six and - man so
here's another stack of cash and an that
penny literally went and some change
our man Ali yeah by being a part of
somebody in lefke right has made nearly
$700 this football season I counted way
to go there's some free window green so
if you come on our showroom bow yeah you
heard his analysis about Chiefs chargers
because you were hiding behind stage
which is what have you been thinking
about this game because it's the last
Thursday Night Football game of the year
so we wanted to make it special
I think um but listening to mr. Sims
don't listen to me too much I agree it's
gonna be a shootout yeah I think it's
gonna be a lot of scoring I looked at
some of the stats Lamar Jackson I think
rushed for like 74 yards
I know Phillip Rivers isn't gonna do now
that's all happen not so you eliminate
that I think um what's the spread
three Chiefs buy some home she got home
favored by three and they're still
fighting for home field yesterday yes
they do they gotta come out and play
yeah I like them I don't think they'll
another day to be that close Chiefs I am
a thousand percent valiant I am too I'm
riding with him - I am I like I was
nervous before the year that the
somebody in Lefko Bank would be
dwindling down and instead mainly
because of Ally we are at around $6,000
we started at $5,000 right and Ally was
the huge part of that demand dude thanks
for dealing with me and some of my you
know absolutely hatred towards you no
problem I'm a fan that's your dad there
you come on my show and take a blow for
Sims peace out homey for Ally yes sir I
am the lef koe man
we will holla holla holla at you later
enjoy the game
all right down y'all next week this will
go right next to the I Aaron Rock
[Music]
we both like the song I've been working
on the railroad except we don't call it
that but that's what the song is to me
always what are you talking about the
eyes of Texas or Oh ball you oh hey
what's up homies thanks for watching
subscribe to the bee our YouTube channel
man you're such a millennial also while
you're here we have a lot of other
videos check them out and then what time
does our show come out Wednesday 8:00
p.m. be there or be square
he ruined it it was really close